[موسيقى]
موستار المدينه الهادئه تجسد جزءا مهما في
تاريخ حرب البوسنه والهرسك شيدت على يد
العثمانيين وشهدت ازدهرا في القرنين
الخامس عشر والسادس عشر وابان اوجل
امبراطوريه النمساويه المجريه في القرنين
التاسع عشر والعشرين تتميز بيوتها وازقتها
بالطراز المعماري وتحوي جسرا تاريخيا يحمل
اسم الجسر العتيق او مستار الذي اكسبها
اسمه الا ان الجزء الاكبر من المدينه
التاريخيه والجسر القديم الذي صممه
المهندس الشهير سنان دمر خلال النزاعات
التي اندلعت في تسعينيات القرن الماضي اذ
تعرض الجسر للقصف بالمدفعيه من قبل القوات
الكرواتيه خلال الحرب في البوسنه والهرسك
في الثامن من نوفمبر
وانهار بعد قصفه باكثر من 60
شكل تدمير الجسر عقبه كبيره في تنقل
المواطنين من والى جانبي النهر وقد اعاقب
الفتره بعد الحرب البوسنيه طرح عده خطط
لاعاده بناء الجسر بخصائصه الهندسيه التي
ترقى الى فتره ما قبل الحقبه العثمانيه
والعثمانيه الشرقيه
والمتوسطيه والاوروبيه الغربيه واشرف على
المشروع الثقافي كل من البنك الدولي
ومنظمه اليونسكو كما حرصت كل من ايطاليا
وهولندا وتركيا وكرواتيا على تقديم الدعم
واعاده بناء الجسر على غرار البناء القديم
والتراث المعماري الاصلي وقد تم استخدام
احدث المواد والتقنيه الحديثه في عمليه
البناء واستمرت الاعمال الانشائيه للجسر
اكثر من ثلاثه اعوام ليتم اعاده افتتاحه
للماره في الثالث والعشرين من يوليو 2004
وادرجت منظمه اليونسكو الجسر كموقع
للتراثي العالمي
تاريخ جميل وعميق نحاول الترويج لزياره
هذه المدينه الكثيرون ياتون لزيارتها تبدو
وكانها تحمل طبقات من التاريخ الذي مر بها
وكانها قطعه بقلاوه
نظرا لموقع موستار الجغرافي جنوب البوسنه
والهرسك وقربها من الحدود الكرواتيه نجد
في تلك المنطقه تنوع ثقافي وديني على
ضفتين نحن
الضفه الغربيه من البوسنه بكنائسها
وثقافتها الغربيه وتبدو جليه في شوارعها
اثار الدمار والحرب والبيوت المدمره اما
شرقا فهنا المساجد وماذنها والمقاهن
بوسنيه العثمانيه والمقابر الاسلاميه يشعر
زائرها لاول وهله وكانه يتجول في احدى
المدن التركيه
[موسيقى]
بعد صراع طار لاعوام بين ضيفتين نحن ريد
يقطع جسم ستار التاريخي خلفي والذي يعني
حراس الجسر عند ترجمه معناها الى اللغه
العربيه تعود الحياه اليوم الى هنا لتبعث
التفاؤل وحب الاخر في هذا البلد المتعدد
الاعراق والدي انات والثقافات الاثنيه
بالرغم من ان لغه واحده تجمعهم جميعا وهي
اللغه اسلافيه من البلده القديمه في مدينه
موستار
البوسنه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات